hello guys my name is Gregory hello I'm
Caroline Caroline Gibson Mills wonderful
friend of mine from a little acting
class that we take together this small
small space a small space you know
what's funny is a head of the studio
train Ryan Reynolds as a mentor to Ryan
Reynolds and Ryan Reynolds is with Blake
Lively
segue and she is the star of the
shallows don't know what this movie is
about I have gotten several requests to
check it out sorry Ursa yes sir sadly
you don't mean crater
nice great for shot sold lovely Wiley
over here thank you
she is quite groans hey says hey I just
want to let you know I made it here mom
was right
it took forever to find but it's perfect
where did you say your name in these
principles is it's paralyzed
I'm not dying here
thirty forty yards it takes some thirty
two seconds
oh my god it's a scary
whoa Alex terrified it's like what I
love how it's like a cross you know
something that you'd see in like you
know movies that take place in like that
one location you know not necessarily
like buried something along the lines
that mix with jaws of this with this
woman going against the shark in happy
but she like a tactic she's made her on
her poon and like took him out yeah I'm
wondering how she was able to craft so
much things from like these two she's
basically walking wildly brilliant see
this is why you love her as an actress
like she does like this most simple
things they're so intelligent everything
that she does yeah she's very graceful
this could be a movie that really if it
does well if it is well because this
movies like it's riding on her
performance the whole time she's like
the only real main character we really
see going on in the trailer that's gay
interest you see like a one-man show
this person going up against a shark
that's gonna be really exciting what a
scary concept has a terrifying concept
biggest fears yeah it's one of my
biggest fears they don't serve anymore
used to serve I did I used to serve tea
I used to ride the waves of life yeah I
remember just being so free out there
and with my eight pack abs Wow washboard
abs yeah 12 that's it's amazing it's
very impressive
thank you yeah my incredibly toned chest
and all the pot I would smell Wow
yeah but you had a daypack washboard
yeah now I like a definition of
functional stoner yeah yeah but then I
gave up surfing but didn't give up pot
now here we are today this is really
cool at Blake Lively's getting a chance
to do a performance like this because
you know I think females in the business
otherwise known as actresses have much
harder time with getting good like I
could easily have seen like a like a
male actor doing this like but the fact
that they actually like made it a female
character cuz I I love badass female
characters Kill Bill uma Thurman is one
of my favorites and their I love Ripley
from the Alien franchise and like I
forgot the girl's name but the one
was in the latest mission impossible and
Emily Blunt and edge it's a more like I
love the badass female characters and
it's cool that if like Blake Lively can
be like a badass female character I'm
ready for that I'm ready for that girls
do have much tougher time trying to be
tough in this industry it's it's hard
when I'm competing with a lot of very
well trained men so yeah
such as myself mmm correct I'm amazing
at what I do you are I'm amazing
fantastic so the fact that she's back to
me
it's Geoghan please Caroline continue
why are we Fred we're friends because we
like to you know clown around this is us
clowning around the fact that she landed
such a big role in the fact that she
does have to be so tough and kids do you
see her then she got chomped on yeah I
was wondering how she ever that because
that shark seemed massive and was able
to like jump through the air and like
take down one of the humans yeah and uh
how did he not jump on small rock yeah
how do you not jump on the small rock
and how did why do you like over no I
didn't eat her just as she taught yeah
I'm gonna bet tonight's that's got a
little bite it's gettin a little bite
mr. chase come on cheese yeah the shark
never wanted to hurt her he just wanted
to love her he was on the plane with her
yeah what the [ __ ] like lightly it's
okay girl you're a chew toy stand up to
that you know more sharks are killed
every year then a shark kills a human
that's because they taken for their skin
right I don't know all I know is the
Shrek population is becoming endangered
I'm okay with that
yeah I'm surprisingly okay with that
this whole thing about balance I don't
out of the equation I can will adjust I
really just love it I just would like
going to the water way more if I knew
sharks didn't exist anymore I mean every
day yeah looked at me to whale you know
be cool they did this exact movie but
with a way out
somehow we did yeah but on a rock they
should have a franchise out of this
we're political I think it keeps getting
caught up in the same situation oh yeah
I just knew bigger water animals one day
it's just a giant octopus yeah [ __ ]
pounds Blake Lively versus the Kraken
and she's on an even smaller rock oh we
got a crazy French I'd see the pebble in
part three oh the shallow pebble all
right guys
enough enough comedy for you right now
listen if you're new to the channel I
would like it if you could subscribe to
did become a reject because it would be
very valuable on my end and yours as
well hopefully all the cool kids are
reagent-x what he meant to say yeah
think about it the coolest the people
who become the most successful and
coolest tend to start off as being kind
of an outcast a reject you know what I
mean like Shia LaBeouf Caroline Gibson
Mills first off I want to say she has a
wonderful Instagram
thank you very photogenic follow her
there snapchat I don't even have
snapchat but the fact that she has
snapchat eventually how sometimes was
like hey that's a good snap I think you
are in the right game snapchatting she's
just started up a YouTube channel
currently has a video up there but she's
gonna be more active on it I would
subscribe now so that one more videos
come on you'll be the first one ever
they're coming really soon and I would
say the promotion here is done
it is done then yeah this video is over
goodbye